today on the Matt wall show toy
companies are thankful this Christmas
for the rise of a new demographic they
call cadults those are adults who still
buy children's toys for themselves and
there are a lot of them out there we'll
discuss also four female track athletes
challenging the policy of allowing males
to compete against them suffer a defeat
in court the White House tries to
explain what exactly it's been doing to
address the Border crisis the answer is
of course nothing at all and a school in
Maine begins a girl's gender transition
quote unquote while concealing it from
her parents many such cases and they're
all outrageous all of that and more
today on the Matt Walsh show
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
now if you're someone who has always
wanted to read and understand the Bible
but you're not sure where to start then
check out the Bible in a year podcast
from Ascension the Bible and ear podcast
is currently the most popular religion
podcast in the US millions of people
have listened to it and twice it's hit
the number one spot on Apple podcast in
the Bible in a year father Mike Schmitz
reads the entire Bible in a 365 daily
episodes providing helpful commentary
reflection and prayer along the way what
better way to start the new year than
this you can find the Bible in a year
podcast with father Mike Schmitz for
free in your favorite podcast app or on
YouTube plus you can follow along with a
special reading plan to help you better
understand the stories unlike any other
Bible podcast Bible near follows a
special reading plan that organizes the
books of the Bible in a way that helps
listeners understand the story get this
reading plan at ascensionpress.com Walsh
if you want to start reading and more
importantly understanding the Bible this
year go to ascensionpress.com Walsh to
download the reading plan for free
that's ascensionpress.com Walsh to
download the reading plan for free
you probably don't need any more reason
to be frustrated as you Wade through the
holiday crowds to buy the cheap plastic
toy gifts for your children that you
know will all be lost or broken within
three and a half hours of being opened
on Christmas morning but I will give you
another reason anyway so consider that
according to the latest data a
significant portion of the adults in
that crowd are buying toys not for
children but for themselves
in fact if you're not able to find the
exact Barbie playset or Batman action
figure or whatever that you're looking
for it could be because some adult has
already purchased the last one
not for his kid but for himself CNBC
reports this morning about a new group
of consumers that have been dubbed kids
alts
these uh emotionally stunted
intellectually shallow overgrown ever
overgrown adolescence well into their
30s or 40s and yet apparently still I
don't know riding around on Big Wheels
drinking their juice boxes may be
destroying Society but they're doing
wonders for the toy industry so that's
the good news this is from the report it
says there are two things keeping the
toy industry afloat right now inflation
and a consumer group known as cadults
these kids at heart are responsible for
one-fourth of all toy sales annually
around nine billion dollars worth and
are the biggest driver of growth
throughout the industry according to
data from the NPD group
this cohort which NPD defines as ages 12
and older has been steadily contributing
to the industry for years but spending
has accelerated in the wake of the
pandemic leading to year-over-year gains
despite tough comparisons it's an
industry moment for the toy industry
it's an important moment for the toy
industry too with the holiday season
upon us while sales surged across the
board for board games puzzles and
playsets during the pandemic the first
nine months of 2022 saw a three percent
decline in sales volume higher toy
prices helped outweigh these losses as
sales revenue for the time period jumped
three percent NPD reported cadults who
tend to spend more on toys have a great
fondness for cartoons superheroes and
collectibles that remind them of their
childhood they buy merchandise such as
action figures Lego sets and dolls that
might typically be considered for kids
however in recent years toy makers have
created product Lines Just for these
consumers realizing that demand is high
for this generation of adults who still
want to have fun
so as the economy struggles and more and
more adults drop out of the workforce
entirely adults are at the same time
spending more money than ever on
children's toys for themselves
I hate to be the bearer of bad news here
but this is um not a sign of a healthy
Society now granted if 12 years old is
the cutoff then some of these cadults
are actually just kids
and the good news is that if your 12
year old is still playing with Legos
that's uh that's a great sign actually
he has his innocence still and Legos are
a hell of a lot more wholesome and
productive than staring at screens all
day as most 12 year olds do these days
unfortunately
so that's fantastic a 12 year old
playing with Legos but the fact remains
that a great number of the people in
this demographic are in fact actual
adults Millennials and gen xers who
refuse to let go of their childhoods no
matter what
The Today Show highlights uh some more
of the people in this group let's watch
record the guy on a million toys at Toys
R Us that I can play with everybody
knows the song it's that classes 80s
commercial for Toys R Us and it turns
out a kid can always be a kid it's true
there's a growing Trend that finds more
and more adults buying toys for
themselves the group being called
Kittles and it's proving to be a very
big business and our kid at heart NBC
News Now anchored Joe fires here with
more this is a thing huh yeah good
morning I don't want to grow up either
you know new data is showing that people
age 12 and older those are adults 12 and
older they now make up at least a
quarter of toy consumers and the
industry is cashing in with new products
marketed specifically toward Millennials
even gen xers
toys of Christmas Past are now
revisiting many in their adulthood from
adult Happy Meals here are the fries
and then a toy
Barbie to Barbie he's starring in a new
movie coming out next summer
Nostalgia is a driving force for a
growing consumer group called The Kid
alt CNBC reports that data from market
research company NPD group show adults
who are young at heart spend about nine
billion dollars annually for the past
two plus years adults really started to
gravitate towards toys and games not
just to spend more time with their
families which they were doing at home
but also for themselves to de-stress
Aaron muterick is a former software
engineer turned connoisseur of putty he
says grown-ups are stuck on reliving
simpler times from their childhood I
think there is some level of nostalgia
Putty was introduced in the late 1950s
to Children we've seen it time and again
where adults maybe think it is four
children but then once they touch the
putty that their children have they they
want one for themselves
God help us all I mean it's gotten to
the point where adults who play video
games all day are essentially this
generation's version of a man reading a
leather-bound book in his study while
smoking a pipe I mean the gamer is
mature and refined compared to a 40 year
old man who sits around playing with
silly putty all day now what's the
problem here
well the situation situation already
feels rather hopeless based on the fact
that we even need to explain the problem
what's the problem with adults sitting
around all day playing with toys I I
mean it should be self-evident that your
Society is not in Tip-Top shape when
adults are spending billions of dollars
on children's toys that they will play
with themselves
shows not only a catastrophic lack of
maturity in the culture but also a
misalignment of priorities a level of
shallow materialism that is certainly
unprecedented in the history of the
world I mean this this would all seem to
me to be totally self-evident but if I
must flesh it out then I would simply
make
the following observation so first
nobody is saying that we should not have
fun as adults there's nothing wrong with
fun and Recreation on the contrary these
are important parts of a whole and
well-lived life
yet everything must be done in the right
proportion and in a way that is properly
ordered our trouble is that Recreation
has become the primary if not sole focus
of many people's lives and what's more
their idea of recreation their idea of
fun
has not grown or evolved over time they
have grown physically but their tastes
have not
this is one of the most glaring signs of
emotional immaturity and the thing about
emotionally immature people is that if
you ever talk about the problem of
immaturity they will laugh at you which
is exactly how you would expect an
immature person to respond
of course if we lived in a culture that
was filled with mature interesting
competent adults adults with useful
skills adults capable of having
intelligent conversations able to grasp
and to express nuanced ideas adults who
eagerly accept the duties and
responsibilities of adulthood Etc if
that was the case
and still many of these adults also
happen to be obsessed with superheroes
and cartoons and action figures then we
might just chalk it up to a weird sort
of Quirk or eccentricity in our culture
and not really worry much about it
beyond that
but that is not the sort of culture that
we find ourselves in instead we are
surrounded
by Immature idiots who have the skill
sets reasoning skills and Ambitions and
motivations of children
and they also happen to have the hobbies
and Recreations of children and so we
can conclude I think logically
that all of these things are probably
related that the billions spent on the
toys the obsession with Nostalgia is
both a symptom and a driver of the
overall problem
and the overall problem is that the real
business of adulthood is being delayed
and sometimes shirked entirely this is
uh most obvious when we see the numbers
of people refusing to start families and
have kids of their own I mean it's no
surprise
that that's the case given that that you
know they see themselves as kids so they
don't want to have kids
and since that's how they've chosen to
live they also don't realize
that not only is it possible to have fun
as an adult like an adult but you can
even be a real adult
and still enjoy the toys and games of
childhood
like I'm not even saying that when you
become an adult you can never pick up a
toy ever again
but here's the difference
you know those childhood toys
you're supposed to be playing with those
with your own kids I was just playing
with Batman action figures yesterday
okay just yesterday I was but I was
playing with my son it was something I
was doing with him
I wouldn't sit down on the floor by
myself and play with Batman toys
because I'm a grown man and there was a
time when a grown man sitting on the
floor and playing with action figures by
himself would be immediately seen as
mentally handicapped and probably
institutionalized for it
yet when you're playing with your
children it's a different story I have
indeed experienced once again many of
the joys of a of childhood
but from the perspective of an adult who
is now helping to introduce those Joys
to my own children and the joy that I
derive from it now is largely in seeing
and being a part of their Joy this is
supposed to be one of the Hallmarks of a
stable functional well-rounded adult
that you learn how to find happiness in
helping other people to be happy
now another Point here I made the same
observation when we were uh discussing
the adult Happy Meals a few weeks ago
and and you know we hear so much about
how
um my generation and is obsessed with
Nostalgia this is like the millennial
things always talking about their
Nostalgia constantly pining for the
innocence of their childhood growing up
in the 90s you know and there's
something wrong with nostalgia
unless it totally consumes your life and
becomes your entire personality
but also think about what they are
nostalgic for
their Nostalgia is all tied to Brands
their Nostalgia is is a corporate
invention they're nostalgic for Consumer
products they're nostalgic for
entertainment franchises
it is a very particular very modern kind
of nostalgia that is easy for Brands to
exploit and monetize because they
invented it
but it's not the kind of nostalgia that
drives people towards better more
complete and fulfilling lives it just
doesn't now a Nostalgia for experience
a Nostalgia for family Nostalgia for
actual meaningful events that you uh
went through and experience as a child
that can drive you in a good and
worthwhile way
so you know I I find myself nostalgic
for the family dinners that we would
have when I was a child with my parents
and my five brothers and sisters and we
would all sit around and have these big
dinners and uh I can be nostalgic for
that well guess what now I have six kids
of my own and I find myself back at the
dinner table again with four of them
because two are still unborn but find
myself back at the dinner dinner table
again
recapturing that experience and passing
it down to my kids
who I hope will pass it to theirs and so
on that's the sort of generational
passing that we're supposed to be doing
not passing down
entertainment franchises
I remember when I watched this franchise
when I was a child and that it's like
experience things that you did things
that meant something that's what you're
supposed to be passing down
to your kids the problem is that so many
in my generation they were they were
latchkey kids who came home to empty
houses and divorced parents and ate
dinner on the couch watching TV
and so their Nostalgia is not for the
experience
but for the thing they were watching
last point you know you notice the way
that things have completely flipped
upside down
we have these adults
clinging to their childhoods
while at the same time we rip the
childhood away from actual children
so children have their innocence stolen
by groomers in public schools by you
know early exposure to porn and all of
the debased and degraded things that
kids are exposed to intentionally all
the time and it's this it's this
mechanism which is which is intended to
corrupt children to destroy their
innocence
and at the same time when Society is
engineering this corruption it is also
beckoning towards adults telling them to
come back and become kids again
it's almost like we're trying to switch
places
it's totally inverted and perverse
and and we need to flip things back
around and set it right let the kids be
kids they're the kids let them if you're
gonna be obsessed with Nostalgia and
childhood innocence be obsessed with
protecting the innocence of actual
children it's their turn to be kids now
we had our chance it's over
we're adults now
let the kids be kids
you know there's a reason why scripture
says when I was a child I spoke as a
child I understood as a child I thought
as a child but when I became a man I put
away childish things
it is time to do that
well past time
to put away the childish things
now let's get to our five headlines
well the lack of a red wave during the
midterms lead to more Reckless spending
by a more emboldened Administration
higher taxes deeper inflation if you're
unsure how the next two years will
unfold talk to Birch gold group today
about protecting your savings with gold
Birch gold makes it easy to convert your
IRA or 401K into an IRA and precious
metal so you can own gold and silver and
attack sheltered account gold is the
world's oldest most proven form of
currency when inflation soars and all of
their assets go sideways gold is still
there this month you can get a free gold
back with every five thousand dollar
purchase when you convert an existing
Ira or 401K into a previous into a
precious metals Ira with Birch gold by
December 22nd all you gotta do is text
Walsh to 98 98 98 Birch gold will help
you own gold and also silver in a tax
sheltered account so text Walsh to 98 98
98 to claim your free info kit on gold
and talk to one of their precious metal
Specialists with every purchase you make
before December 22nd you'll get a free
gold back this is is a great stocking
stuffer just in time for Christmas text
Walsh to 98 98 98 and protect yourself
with gold today
by the way it is uh official now I
should tell you we were um
speaking of childish things we were all
competing in this daily wire fantasy
football tournament and it is official
that I will be the ultimate loser I did
come in last place
my strategy of never updating my team or
even looking at it one time turns out
that wasn't the best approach that's not
the best strategy so it would seem that
fantasy football leagues are um not like
you know say crock pot beef stew where
you could just set it down and leave it
and come back when it's finished doesn't
work that way so anyway consequences
that is that I'm a loser and I'm
required now to go and attend a WNBA
game there's no way around it there's no
fine print there's no legalistic
Maneuvers I just have to do it and I
understand it and I will okay I will in
a way I'm looking forward to it
that's a little bit too strong I'm not
when I say looking forward to it I mean
that I'm dreading it like a condemned
man dreads his execution but there is I
I do feel maybe honored is what I should
be saying because I as someone who
admires pioneers and explorers I uh feel
honored that I will be
the first human being to ever attend a
WNBA game in person I'm in a way I'm
going to sort of be discovering
um the WNBA so going where no man has
ever gone before only question now is
what to wear for the big day and
originally we had talked about wearing a
free Brittany Griner shirt
a little redundant now because she's
free
so now the thought is maybe I wear a
shirt that says uh trade her back
which
would be a little provocative but if
you're gonna if we're gonna do it if
we're gonna do this thing if we're
trolling that WNBA game then I think you
got to go all the way okay
um
so we'll start with this for the daily
wires there's four female athletes who
sued over Connecticut transgender Sports
policy lost their case in federal court
on Friday a three-judge panel on the
second Circuit Court of Appeals affirmed
a lower Court's decision to throw out
the girls case which are seeking to
scrap a policy that allows biological
males to compete on girls sports teams
in Connecticut
the four track athletes Selena Soul who
you may remember from
what is a woman she appeared in that
Chelsea Mitchell Alana Smith and Ashley
nicoletti and their mothers had argued
in their suit that Connecticut's High
School Sports Authorities policy
allowing transgender students to compete
on girls teams just disadvantages female
athletes and has caused them to lose out
on opportunities and awards
yes they're arguing that because that is
obviously the case I mean there's it's
not even really an argument it's just a
fact you can look at the times and you
can see that you know we could see which
girls in particular lost out on what
opportunities and what medals and what
awards that they would have otherwise
gotten because the field was crowded out
by these uh by these two males
they had asked for the court uh the
court for an injunction to erase the
victories of two biological male
transgender athletes who broke the 17
girls uh track broke 17. get this right
they broke 17 girls track records
so these are records that were broken 17
of them
by boys
and so boys now own 17 girls records in
track and field
uh and they also snagged 15 women's
State Track championship titles
in 2019 two transgender athletes
finished ahead of Seoul causing her to
miss out on a qualifying for finals and
the opportunity to compete before
College Scouts
um Mitchell has missed out on state
championship title uh titles four
different times because she finished
behind transgender athletes
but
the uh the court said that uh just
struck this down and uh
they lost their appeal
um
yet again
now
the important thing to remember is
always about these cases and like
not that this even matters that much
because the fact is that these boys did
not belong competing against the girls
no matter what because they're not girls
and that's it that's all we need to say
about it
but it is also notable that these boys
were once again
not dominant male athletes they were
middle of the pack
and this is in a sport like track and
field
it's really easy to see all this because
it's one of the most probably the most
quantifiable sport in existence it's
very simple you're just running and
whoever gets their quickest wins and you
have the times and all of that so you
can look at their times and you can see
that against the boys with the ties
they're finishing in their Races they
were middle of the pack they weren't
even qualifying for Championship
um Championship matches they weren't
even they weren't getting to the states
or anything like that uh and then they
go over to the girls and you take these
middle to pack mediocre boys put them
against the girls and they are
dominating nearly every single race that
they run taking 17 records
no better Testament both to the insanity
of this policy and also to the
difference between girls and boys
and I'm still waiting it's just it is it
is a fascinating
coincidence isn't it that we still have
not seen a dominant male athlete
discover that he's female isn't it just
you know maybe maybe uh we could get a
study done on this or something like
that why is it
that there are plenty of male athletes
who discovered they have women trapped
inside them magically so this seems to
happen a lot
but they're always middle of the pack
they're always mediocre it's never the
ones at the top
it's always the mediocre athletes who
and usually it's like they've been
competing against the boys for a while
and then at some point they they realize
you know what I think I'm actually a
girl turns out what do you know
I mean I don't know is it because if
you're racing against the boys or
competing against the boys and you're
dominating there that there's no
incentive to want to race against the
girls
you're already getting all the gold
medals and you're getting it against
tougher competition and so you'll take
that you'd prefer those accolades
but if you have to choose between being
a mediocre nobody uh male athlete or a
dominant pretend female athlete you'll
choose that could that be the reason
who knows in fact everyone knows um
who's honest about it
okay another report from the daily wire
systems the Supreme Court has uh blocked
the bite Administration from lifting
title 42 the statute which gives
commanders in Chief the power to shut
down immigration as an emergency action
to keep communicable diseases out of the
United States was last used by former
president Donald Trump in reaction to
the covet outbreak families seeking
Asylum had filed a lawsuit in which led
to a federal judge ordering the byte
Administration to lift title 42 by
Wednesday
an order from Chief Justice John Roberts
staying the ruling stay the ruling of
the lower court
Greg Abbott said in response Texas and
other states are insisting the court
leaves title 242 in place today's order
is a step in the right direction this
helps prevent illegal immigration
so this was supposed to be lifted I
believe uh tomorrow
and now for right now anyway the order
has been stayed
um if it does end then the floodgates
are going to open
and even more than they already are
and it'll be even more of of a disaster
especially for uh towns that are down on
the border now the bite Administration
they've been hiding behind the fact that
that you know this was originally a
court order that was supposedly telling
them that they have to lift title 42.
what they what they don't want you to
know is that they sought to lift it this
is what they wanted
as this surprisingly skeptical
journalist pointed out to Karen Jean
pair yesterday let's watch this
if you're saying that Republicans aren't
doing the work
um to get this done and then you have
someone like Joe manchin saying well the
president has the ability to ask for an
extension he should be asking for an
extension because we're at this point
where you got a deadline and a crisis is
that within the president's authority to
do that
so look we were made we remained under a
court order to lift title 42. that is a
court order
that is telling us to lift title 42 and
we're going to comply because we follow
the rule of law that is
but it is a court order but that is that
started by you guys it was a quarterator
that has been provided to us and so now
we have to comply and that is we have to
comply by December 21st it is it is a
law that is
what I'm saying is that what I'm saying
that it is a court order that has been
presented to us that we are going to
comply with
it's always fascinating when these
people decide to care about things like
uh the rule of law it never it just it
always sounds awkward
phrases like rule of law and also Free
Speech coming out of the mouth of a
leftist it always sounds awkward coming
in because it you you know that they
don't actually care about that and uh
it's the last thing that they want to
have to talk about or rely on you know
or fall back on but in this case it's
the rule of law
well the rule of law also says
that we have borders
the rule of law would stipulate that the
borders be protected and that our
immigration laws be enforced that's also
what the rule of law says
for the whole press conference on this
subject was a disaster she was also
asked um what exactly Kamala Harris is
doing on this issue because Camille
Harris is supposed to be this is
supposed to be her thing you know she's
heading up the immigration response and
she's dealing with this crisis
what is she doing though Camilla Harris
besides laughing awkwardly and talking
about Venn diagrams what is she actually
doing
uh Karen Jean pair tried to give us an
answer to that
the president asked the vice president
with studying and working on the root
causes of some of these issues I'm
wondering if there's any update from
this side of the White House on what
she's been doing and what she will
continue to do as we're expecting an
influx at the border as you know the
president uh appreciates the partnership
that he has with the vice president
you're right that has been her charge to
work in a diplomatic way and finding the
root causes of of migration I don't have
anything to lay out specifically on what
that work looks like but again we
appreciate her partnership and I would
probably refer you to her office on
anything specific on the work that she's
doing
it's been it's been over two years you
don't have anything specific at this
point would this work in any other
context like would could you get away
with that at your job
with your boss and we are
allegedly supposed these are our they're
working for us supposedly and so we're
supposed to be the bosses and uh when
so if we want to know like what are you
guys doing about this they should be
able to give us some sort of answer uh
yeah they can get away with us you
couldn't you know if your boss gave you
a project and said uh here's what you
need to do this is the problem you need
to solve two years later you get called
into the office so uh give me the
updates on that well I don't have
anything specific at this point
um I but we it's certainly Something
That We're moderate monitoring and we're
you know I'm I'm thinking quite a lot
about it
um I've I've made some Venn diagrams if
you want to see them
you could never get away with that but
they can
um meanwhile Texas border towns as
mentioned like El Paso are bracing
and uh here's an MSNBC report which also
maybe someone surprisingly is even
talking about this issue but here it is
right now as we speak it is 30 degrees
Fahrenheit that's below freezing in El
Paso Texas where hundreds of people
including children are sleeping on the
streets after crossing the southern
border the mayor of that City declared a
state of disaster this weekend saying
Asylum Seekers are not safe with
shelters and processing centers at
capacity and in just two days that my
Administration is ordered to stop using
title 42 the Border policy Health policy
the U.S has used to turn back two and a
half million Asylum Seekers since
president Trump enacted it in March of
2020 an appeals court denied the
extension requested by 19 Republican
states on Friday clearing the way for
the change unless the Supreme Court
weighs in before the 21st
humanitarian crisis yes well you know
the um
the Mantra of peace through strength is
probably never more applicable
than at the border
because if you want to stop this
do you want to stop it well they'd
obviously don't
but if you do want to stop this you want
to help these people if you want to
dissuade more of this you want to end
the humanitarian crisis
then there's a way to do it you
militarize the Border
you round people up
people are coming across the border
illegally you round them up at gunpoint
um just like they do in many other
countries across the world
you know if you try to sneak across the
border in many other countries countries
that take their border seriously
uh you're gonna find there's me guns
pointed at you
and then you eject them from the country
you know you start using very harsh and
immediate methods
you become absolutely ruthless in the
defense of the border and of national
sovereignty
you let people know that it's not worth
it to come here it's not worth it to try
to invade the country this way
um it's not worth it to come here
illegally it's not worth it to to to try
this
not worth the risk
it's not worth the price you will pay
you do that and it's the best thing
first and foremost for American citizens
because you're defending American
sovereignty
but also for the potential illegal
immigrants
it is it is the most Humane and
responsible thing if you don't want to
end up with uh illegal immigrants that
are you know huddling around lying on
the street lying on sidewalks and
freezing cold temperatures
if you don't want people bringing kids
across the border
or even worse giving their kids to human
traffickers who bring the kids across if
you don't want that
then the only way to stop it
is to not only round up the people that
are here to stop it but actually but you
know that's that's only one thing you
can stop the people that are coming
across we're not even doing that but you
can do that but then what do you do to
stop people from wanting to come in the
first place that's the actual issue
that's what Camilla Harris is supposedly
working on what are the root causes
that that is a good question
not a difficult question to answer
but the root cause of uh you know the
fundamental root cause of people
you know trying you know trying to sneak
across the border in droves not even
sneaking but just coming across
fundamentally it's because they believe
that they can they know they can
they know it's an option
you know I always say this when we talk
about illegal immigration I don't for me
it's uh it's it's it's nothing personal
like
yes I'm in favor of actually building a
wall uh militarizing the Border rounding
people up being beat being again
ruthless in defense of the border is
nothing personal for me against illegal
immigrants if I lived in Mexico
I would not want to be in Mexico I would
all I would want to be here and and I
don't know if I live there and I thought
it was an option to just walk across the
border
and I thought that I could do that and
then I'd be here and I wouldn't be there
anymore I'd probably do it
I understand why people do it
you look at the places that they're
leaving I wouldn't want to live in those
places either
and if you believe that you can just
walk across as simple as that why not
of course they don't have any respect
for our laws because they don't they're
not citizens here why would they respect
them
I mean I I don't I don't have a ton of
respect for other countries laws I don't
need to I don't live there but it's not
so
yeah I can I can understand that
which is why it's nothing personal when
I say that these people need to be
rounded up and ejected from the country
it's just what needs to happen
for their sake and for ours
um all right
here's a report this is from a website
called the mainwire mainwire.com
um Maine is in the state of Maine a
public school worker at Great Salt Bay
Community School who coached a 13 year
old girl into a gender transition
without telling her parents
has only a conditional license to
practice social work in Maine the main
wire has learned Amber Levine the mother
of the young girl revealed at a school
board meeting on Wednesday that she
discovered a chest binder in her
daughter's bedroom several weeks ago her
daughter told her that the binder was
provided by a social worker at the
public school who encouraged her to keep
it secret from her parents
that's when Levine learned that the
social worker and other school staff had
started a social gender transition for
the girl in October without her parents
knowledge or consent sources have
confirmed the social worker in question
is Sam Roy a 26 year old University of
Maine graduate student who has a
conditional license from the state of
Maine to work as a social worker Roy
started from started working with the
damariscada school this fall Roy is
scheduled to graduate next year from the
University of Maine with his master's
degree in social work
so he doesn't even have to have the
degree yet but he has taken charge of
this girl's quote unquote social
transition
um Levine learned that the school had
begun transitioning her daughter when
she discovered a chest binder in the
girl's bedroom chest binder is a device
that flattens the appearance of a
woman's breasts they're sometimes used
by individuals suffering from gender
dysphoria or gender confusion unless one
properly binders can cause or exacerbate
health problems
um binders are typically used during
social gender Transitions and are
considered a stepping stone to an
eventual double mastectomy of course
surgery that removes healthy breath
breast tissue
although Levine knew that her daughter
was seeing a social worker through the
school she did not know that her
daughter was reassigned to rule in
October she has never seen or talked to
Roy okay
so this is and this is uh
not as unusual as we want to think it is
certainly not unprecedented
where a school is
it's not even just that the school knows
that a child identifies as the other
gender and is not telling the kid the
parent about it that's bad enough that's
already horrific
uh for the school I mean schools should
not
a school should not know anything about
your child that you do not know
there should be no information at all
none that the school knows about your
kid that you don't know
because when we talk about the school
the school is not some sort of amorphous
uh entity it's we're talking about
people
and so is there any individual person
who works at the school who has a right
to know information about your child
that you don't
obviously not
and that is especially the case when it
comes to something like this so that's
bad enough if they're just concealing
just I mean if they're concealing this
kind of information but in this case
they are actually
facilitating this quote-unquote
transition themselves
took it upon themselves to do that
of course while not only not telling the
parents but actively concealing it from
them
by the way this article says that uh I I
want to make sure to note this the
article says
that chest binders unless worn properly
can are damaging well that's that's
there is no proper way to wear them they
are damaging period
the the whole point is to flatten you
know um the chest it's there's there's
no healthy or proper way to do that
there are ways that are
you know so when we talk about proper or
healthy way of wearing a chest binder
what they really mean to say are here's
the way to do it that will supposedly
mitigate some of the harm that this is
going to cause the child but there still
will be harm no matter how you slice it
um and this is all this is one step
towards the towards the surgery
so when the left says
that are they're not they're not
performing these surgeries on kids
that's a lie first of all they are
performing surgeries on kids they're
performing double mastectomies on girls
as young as 15 14 years old maybe even
younger
but also the the so-called social
transition
that is about putting the child on the
conveyor belt
which leads directly to the surgery
and most of the kids will stay on that
conveyor belt
all the way down you know until they get
to the part where with with the saws and
the blades
that's what it's about
um
and the schools they don't see any
problem with this
because as far as they're concerned
it these kids are theirs the kids belong
to them
and you should know that so I'm always
preaching about homeschool
but if you can't do homeschool and you
feel like you have to send your kid to
public school it really should be the
last resort but if you're going to do it
then you should you should just
understand that you cannot you cannot
implicitly trust anyone there
you especially can't trust counselors
therapists social workers
I mean you can't we're at a point now
it's sad to say
where you can't trust people in that
field at all
I mean that entire field is
ideologically captured it is hostile to
you and uh it just is you cannot trust
it
I would not send my kid to any of these
people period especially not unattended
so if your kid does you know if you
really feel like your kid needs to see
some sort of counselor then you need to
be in the room
but the schools this is what they
believe that they they own your kids the
kids belong to them you are um
talk about things being inverted you
know you are you're the the hot you are
basically the hired help and they
have ownership of your child that's how
they see it
all right one other thing to get to this
is a from the Sun it says Britney
Spears's father last night defended the
controversial legal order that sparked
worldwide outrage insisting she could
have died without it speaking
exclusively for the first time about the
13-year conservatorship which controlled
almost every aspect of the troubled us
pop star's life Jamie Spears claims he
is far from the monster he has been
painted as in his first interview in
more than a decade Jamie speaking ahead
of a book by Britney's ex-husband Kevin
Federline about fatherhood in the midst
of public drama said quote my God where
would she be without that
conservatorship now I ain't I ain't
gonna paint you no pretty pictures
that conservatorship was one hell of a
time and without it I don't know if she
would be alive now
Jamie 70 years old has endured slurs
that claimed he wanted power over
Brittany 41 to line his own pockets and
micromanage her career even though he
says all decisions under the order were
taken jointly with a quote group of very
good people her fans saw him as a
controlling Puppet Master you know this
whole this whole story is frustrating to
me
because he had this Pitchfork mob uh
that has assembled demanding that
Britney be released from her
conservatorship despite having
absolutely no idea what was going on
behind the scenes okay no idea and I
made this point at the time it's like
you're calling free Brittany you don't
you have no clue what's actually
happening you don't know you saw a
Netflix documentary
it's all you saw
that wasn't even pretending to be
objective
all they knew is that is what Britney
Spears told them and surprised Britney
Spears doesn't think she should be under
a conservatorship because every person
who is in a conservatorship
doesn't want to be in one that's that's
why that's
just assumed
that doesn't mean that automatically
like any time you're forcing someone to
do something of course you have to force
them which means they probably don't
want to do it but the fact that they
don't want to do it doesn't necessarily
mean that it's wrong
it could I mean it could be wrong but it
depends
like there there are people in the world
who are a danger to themselves and
others
okay whether Britney Spears is one of
those people
that's a different conversation but
those people exist there are those
people out there
and uh for people like that
these kinds of Arrangements can be
necessary because otherwise they're
going to hurt themselves or hurt other
people
now as for Britney Spears what do we
know about her uh well we know a lot but
based on what we knew she was a nut case
she lost custody of her own kids in
California
a woman lost custody of her own kids in
California do you know how utterly
disastrous of a mother you have to be to
lose custody of your kids
in California no less
so we knew that we saw all the crazy
stuff on social media uh we saw how she
Rambles incoherently like even when she
was defending herself and trying to
explain why the conservatorship was
terrible she couldn't string together a
coherent sentence
she's like incoherent
does all of that mean and now she's like
posting 56 nude pictures every day it's
like it's it's like naked babbling
incoherently it's all the signs of a
crazy person
does all that mean that she actually is
crazy well I can't say that for sure
because I don't see what's going on
behind the scenes but but like it seems
like all the signs are pointing in that
direction and there are no signs
pointing to her being actually sane
does that make her dad a good guy no
because he pimped his own daughter out
to the music industry when when she was
like 15 years old
so he at a minimum consented at a
minimum to having his teenage daughter
turned into a you know into what she was
turned into
so um
you know her first song she was like 15
16 when she'd perform that song
so he's obviously not a good guy
which is why if people had been arguing
that someone else should have control
over the conservatorship then that would
be one thing but instead they said free
Brittany
and just Freer entirely
and now she's probably gonna be dead of
a drug overdose within a couple of years
and all of her fans that called for this
like this is going to be partly on them
this is this is what you wanted
like she does anyone think she's going
to live to 50. does anyone think that
does anyone see that happening
seems very unlikely all right let's get
to the comment section
[Music]
if you're listening to the show odds are
that you put a lot of stock and how you
raise your kids you understand that your
children look to you to Define their
values and their perspectives of the
world that's why it's extremely
important that you have a will in place
a will also determines how your
financial assets are dispersed as well
as your personal property it lays out
your Healthcare power of attorney to
ensure that your end-of-life decisions
are carried out if you're just starting
out and you don't have thousands of
dollars to spend on an attorney but you
want to make sure that your savings your
belongings and your family are all
protected you have to create your will
at epicwill.com today epic Wheels early
estate plans start at just 119 and you
can save 10 percent when you use promo
code Walsh go to epicwill.com use promo
code Walsh to save 10 on Epic Will's
complete will package that's
epicwill.com promo code Walsh
all right this is from M says uh my ex
grew up in a religious home but still
got exposed to porn at the age of 12
while a friend's house his friend said
to him hey you want to see something
cool before he knew it he was viewing
this material for the first time on his
friend's desktop uh his parents had zero
clue this experience turned into a
full-blown addiction as one of the
contributing factors to our breakup
point is this smut needs to be outlawed
um
yeah this is uh and and there are so
many stories like this I mean millions
of stories just like this of people who
were exposed to this and and
in a way that
like the person you're talking about
did he have bad or neglectful parents
maybe he did but there's no indication
from the story you just told that he did
given that this stuff and and this I'm
I'm assuming was several years ago at
least
it's only gotten more pervasive since
then
so it would have been difficult enough
like in the early days of the internet
being a sort of a household item
even back then it would have been very
difficult would have been difficult for
parents to hide you know to Shield their
kids from this kind of content
but back then at least the Internet only
existed on
desktop computers and so it was it was
uh much more contained
now everyone is walking around with
devices in their pocket that can access
pornography and so it's just
you can do a lot to Shield your kids
and there's a lot that parents could be
doing that they're not
but there's only so much you can do
given that this stuff is everywhere
and we have just made it impossible for
parents which is why I said yesterday
can is it can we help parents out a
little bit
I just I get so frustrated when I hear
people say oh these parents you know
it's all about the parents
okay easy for you to say
that as a childless person who has no
stake in the future of this country
who has no responsibilities at all you
know you just you were just that Target
of the toy section buying more uh
Spider-Man action figures so it's easy
for you to say parents today
you're not doing anything you'd have no
idea what you're talking about
okay you're still you're still living as
an overgrown child but those of us who
have kids we understand that this that
we have been put in an extremely
difficult situation
we live in a culture that is absolutely
hostile to children and and and there
are booby traps laid out everywhere
and so when we say hey can we get a
little bit of help here
what we get in responses answers this is
your problem
and why do we hear it
like why is that why the hostility it's
again because these people
they they don't want any hindrance or
any inconvenience at all in their
pursuit of masturbation material
and they are willing they they're
willing I mean there are people today
many people
they would be willing to sacrifice the
innocence of a billion kids
just to
make it slightly easier for them to
masturbate to pornography
and if that sounds like a like you have
to be a sociopath to well yeah we're
surrounded by sociopaths
um
let's see Lena McCune says it's scary
how they expect parents to keep their
kids off porn but also increase the
amount of work expected to be done on
the internet I'll keep my child off the
internet as much as humanly possible but
I don't feel confident that you won't
see something inappropriate yeah another
perfect example is what I'm talking
about not making it easier on parents so
always say keep the kids off the
internet more and more the schools are
saying you have to be on the internet
there's we're structuring life around
the internet
um
Becky says I know someone who has been
addicted to pornography since he was
eight eight he's married with two kids
now one on the way uh and his marriage
is suffering porn is absolutely evil for
children obviously and adults
eight years old
I mean kids are being exposed to this
stuff
this is it's it's bad enough if you had
a healthy childhood and
um you were introduced to
[Music]
um
human sexuality in a healthy way
and and then you find pornography so
that's bad enough but in this case
you're taking kids and this is their
introduction it's not like a biology
lesson it's not anatomy class it's not a
birds and the bees talk from their
parents their introduction is
um whatever you find on PornHub
this this is the Gateway in so from the
very beginning like this goes all the
way to the root
for them
from the very beginning their concept of
human sexuality and the sexual act and
all of that has been totally shaped by
what they see on the internet
and Kaizo Kudos says if you've ever
wondered what Christmas cards from this
man would be like well death is
inevitable Merry Christmas from Matt
Walsh that is you know what
in its own way I consider that a message
of merriment and joy
we're just days away from Christmas and
you can't hide from the truth any longer
you still
don't have gifts for everyone on your
list you know it and although you may be
attempted to disown them altogether
rather than Brave the last minute
Christmas rush Jeremy's razors is here
to help Jeremy's e-gift cards are the
perfect present for all those woke free
folks you narrowly neglected and they're
100 guaranteed to arrive in time for
Christmas that's right not even Joe
Biden's supply chain can prevent your
friends and family from unwrapping a
great gift on the big day and whether
they opt for the Precision 5 razor with
a flip back trimmer tea tree and argon
oil shampoo and conditioner or even the
luxurious beard kit you and your gift
card recipients can take extra Merriman
knowing that you've helped make woke
razor companies that hate you even
poorer bring a gift not an excuse go to
dailywire.com Walsh to pick up your
Jeremy's razors e-gift cards and put the
finishing touches to your Christmas
shopping today now let's get to our
daily cancellation
foreign
daily cancellation I must Circle back to
something from last week you may recall
early the previous week when Elon Musk
got himself into trouble with the woke
Brigade for making fun of the preferred
pronoun ritual and we discussed the
issue on this show and I explained as I
have many times in the past that it's
not only valid but necessary to mock
preferred pronouns because the whole
concept of preferred pronouns is
fundamentally nonsensical and that's not
just because men are demanding that
incorrect female pronouns be used for
them and vice versa but because the
entire concept of a person having a
preference when it comes to pronouns the
idea that they can have a pronoun at all
is incoherent and I made the same point
on Twitter where I posted quote
uh nobody has pronouns you can't have a
pronoun any more than you can have a
preposition or an adverb the concept
doesn't make any sense pronouns are not
things you can own they aren't pets or
accessories they are parts of speech
that's it you don't get to customize
them
so that's what I said my point pretty
basic self-explanatory hard to
misinterpret you would think now it will
uh surprise you to learn that this uh
surprise you to learn this probably but
I've I've been trying to spend a little
bit less time on Twitter recently so I
never checked to see how people
responded to that tweet and I didn't
know that it had gone relatively viral
and the left had seized on it and they
were trying to dunk on it I was
oblivious to all of this and they were
dunking for days and I didn't even know
like the proverbial falling tree they
were dunking in the forest but nobody
was there to see them so did they really
dunk at all that's a philosophical
question but then this weekend came and
I was I was uh flying back and forth
from Phoenix and I was bored on the
plane and so I went back and uh I
stumbled upon these responses
to summarize basically the leftists on
Twitter had apparently decided
that my argument was hilarious and
ridiculous and stupid because as so many
pointed out
I was using pronouns
while tweeting against pronouns yes they
had decided that I was making an
anti-pronoun case
I'm against pronouns as a concept I'm
opposed to anyone using pronouns for any
reason they decided and so it's very
funny that even while telling people not
to use pronouns I was using them myself
Checkmate they got me now one example of
this rebuttal came from a woman named
Jessica Piper her response caught my eye
in particular because she is apparently
a teacher an English teacher and she's
also a former political candidate but
it's her status as a teacher that makes
the following response from her quite
troubling she said quote
they aren't sending their brightest are
they the first word in this rant against
pronouns is a pronoun laughing face
emoji she continues grammar check how
many pronouns are in this message
against using pronouns that includes an
accompanying uh Tick Tock video where
she circles all the pronouns in my tweet
with the Curb Your Enthusiasm music in
the background because aren't I such a
dummy for being anti-pronoun even while
using pronouns
now
if you have better reading comprehension
skills than our friend Jessica you've
already made note of the problem here
I of course never said that we shouldn't
use pronouns I'm not against pronouns I
have not taken an anti-pronoun stance
I'm saying that I'm saying not that
pronouns can't be used
but that they can't be possessed they
can't be owned like a pet pronouns are
not fashion accessories you don't have
pronouns
people use pronouns they use pronouns to
refer to you but the pronouns that they
choose when referring to you are not
meant to reflect your preferences or
your self-image they are not borrowing
your pronouns so that they can use them
okay it's not the way it works excuse me
sir if that's what you are may I borrow
your pronouns that's not how it works
it's just it's grammar and they are
meant to reflect physical reality that
that's my point you can disagree with it
I suppose you'd be wrong if you
disagreed with it but you're free to be
wrong what you cannot do is invent an
entirely different argument I never made
and then think that you've defeated Me
by tearing down the argument
uh that I didn't make instead of the one
that I did otherwise not of course is
making a straw man now
I made this observation to Jessica and
she responded quote the fact that Matt
Walsh is quote tweeting me on the topic
of grammar a subject which I have a
whole ass degree I bet he's fun at
parties
now I'm not sure what part of this is my
favorite is it that she's bragging about
having a degree in grammar even while
revealing that she has the reading
comprehension skills of a toddler
or is it the fact that she has a degree
it uses phrases like whole ass
or is it the fact that she she sent
three tweets and made a tick tock video
in reaction to my statement he is now
taking offense at the mere fact that I
would dare respond to her at all
or is it the implication that being fun
at a party means agreeing with Jessica
about whatever nonsense she happens to
be spewing
now I very much doubt that Jessica is
getting invited to parties but if she is
she has ironically revealed herself to
be exactly the sort of person that you
avoid at a party at all costs
so take your pick of the litter there I
suppose
this only goes to show
what sort of bind the left finds itself
in
um they cannot defend their position on
pronouns or on gender ideology as a
whole Jessica as an English teacher
cannot begin to articulate an argument
as to why
the pronouns we use to refer to someone
should depend on how that person happens
to be feeling that day rather than being
based on our own perception of physical
reality
she can't explain why we should have our
own preferred pronouns and not our own
preferred adjectives and prepositions
which everyone else is required to
affirm and to use in reference to us
she can't do that in fact she can't
explain why this pronoun customization
only applies to certain pronouns in
certain situations
so
what if I were to make the following
statement
what if I were to say this
I was talking to Jessica Piper about
pronouns we believe that preferred
pronouns are nonsense
now
Jessica would probably object she would
say no we don't believe that you believe
that and you're just you you're not us
it would be no use then for me to
clarify that my preferred pronouns are I
we and US those are my preferred
pronouns
so anytime you talk about me you have to
say I we or us
indeed Jessica would flatly refuse to
use my preferred pronouns in that case
she would say that though I get to
choose my own I can't choose those
why can't I choose those
well because it doesn't make any sense
for me to insist that other people say
the word we when referring to me given
that I am just an individual
I'm not everyone
in other words she will declare that in
this conflict between physical reality
and my perception
physical reality wins out
in this case
but not in others
I'm betting she would say the same if I
told her that my pronouns are me I and
myself
those are my only pronouns therefore
when you refer to me you must say me or
I when talking about me
which means you'll be talking about
yourself because I identify as you and
also me I identify as everyone
your identity has been collapsed into
mine
according to me and it's how I identify
now she probably wouldn't respect that
either she would say that that makes no
sense
you can't identify that way
and even if you do you can't I'm not
going to affirm it
oh so it turns out that I can't just
choose any pronoun I want it turns out
that there are still some rules here
and those rules when they are applied
are based on physical reality they are
based on a need to be coherent
at times a basic level of coherence is
required
but not at all times so I can't have it
would be too incoherent from my pronouns
to be I me or we but if my pronoun was Z
Zer and Zim
literal gibberish that doesn't mean
anything
that's okay so who decides when uh
physical reality trumps self-perception
who decides when it's necessary to be
coherent and when it's not necessary to
be coherent
well I guess Jessica Piper decides her
and people like her
those are the real rules of grammar now
that's what they're going to be teaching
the kids in English class
the rule is they decide what the rules
are
and when they're applied and to whom
that's the logic we get from English
teachers these days and that is why she
and all the rest of them are today
canceled and that'll do it for this
portion of the show is move over to the
members block hope to see you there if
not talk to you tomorrow Godspeed
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]